my biggest
thing that i like to do is discover
stuff
and not necessarily things that have
already been discovered i really like to
discover things that haven't been
discovered yet if you take an asteroid
and you discover an asteroid for example
even though there's half a million of
them out there that's one you found
nobody else in the world knew about that
asteroid before you saw it
what i've been doing here lately and and
for about 15 16 years now
i've been working with near-earth
objects
my observations contribute to
making sure that we don't have something
coming up that's going to fall on our
heads
kind of first got into it probably 10 12
years old i was begging begging begging
to get a telescope and you know we were
in a very rich family so it took a while
to get it and one christmas i got
telescope then i started using it and i
got aperture fever
you want bigger telescopes all the time
so i started learning how to build them
i learned how to how to work in a
machine shop
and i can build things that i wanted to
build
and a lot of that was astronomy parts
i kind of modified my life to fit this
study this kind of lifelong study
sandlot is
a
very tiny little observatory it's only
10 foot by 10 foot wide
the telescope i built uh over a period
of about a year and a half and it may
not look very polished
it works really well
i'm good with that
i i don't have a degree in astronomy
i have a passion for astronomy
and i've done it for many many years and
i've i've contributed i think to the
scientific body of astronomy that's
that's really kind of a
yeah from that standpoint i am an
astronomer